CONVERSATION WITH SENATOR
LINDSAY GRAHAM WHO WAS
ENCOURAGING TO THE PRESIDENT TO
GO AHEAD AND FOLLOW-UP ON THIS
ACTION.
AND HERE IS LIEUTENANT OLIVER
NORTH.
THE PRESIDENT MAKING CLEAR WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT.
THIS IS A PRECISION STRIKE TO
SEND A MESSAGE AND DETERRENT TO
STOP THE USE OF CHEMICAL WEAPONS
AND USE THE PRESIDENT A OWN
WORDS HERE, WHEN HE TALKED
FRANKLY PASSIONATELY ABOUT ALL
OF THIS.
IT IS BAR BA RICHL AND
BRUTALITY.
>> I LAID OUT LAST NIGHT THE
TARGET LIST.
I HAVEN'T TALKED TO ANYBODY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION, I SAID IF
THERE IS GOING TO BE A ATTACK TO
DETER THE USE OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS BY THE SYRIANS IT HAD TO
BE MORE THAN A ONE OFF LIKE LAST
APRIL.
AND IT CLEARLY LOOKS LIKE IT
WILL HIT ECONOMIC TARGET AND
TAKE OUT COMMAND AND CONTROL IN
DAMASCUS.
AND FIRST STAKEOUT, AND SURFACE
TO AIR MISSILES WHICH THE
RUSSIANS PUT IN.
AND FURTHER TO THE COMMENT THAT
ED JUST MADE.
WHEN RONALD REAGAN 32 YEARS AGO
DID THE SAME THING TO GADDAFI,
STRIKES OUT OF GREAT BRITAIN AND
OFF NAVY CARRIERS.
HE DIDN'T GO TO CONGRESS AND HE
JUST DID IT.
AND THEN I HOPE THIS IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DOES TOMORROW AND IF
NECESSARY CONTINUES TO STRIKE AT
TARGET AND MAKE SURE THAT ASSAD
REGIME CANNOT DO IT AGAIN.
GOING AFTER THE SEA PORTS AND
ALL OF THOSE RUNWAY AND COMMAND
AND CONTROL.
I TELL YOU, IF RUSSIANS PERSIST
IN THIS EFFORT TO DENY USE THE
INTELLIGENCE ASSET AND SO CALLED
DRONES AND
DRONES AND  SA
DRONES AND  SATE
DRONES AND  SATELL
DRONES AND  SATELLIT
DRONES AND  SATELLITES
DRONES AND  SATELLITES.